today I made the choice to get a mohawk
let's do this
I'm a working professional 34 years old
I'm married I have two kids so I just
never really had that tenacity to go out
and go do something crazy but I'm down
to try anything once
it feels like she's scraping the last
pieces of hair off my head three two
mohawk oh my kids are gonna freak out my
new hairdo is the craziest you've ever
done hands down my family reacted
exactly as I thought they would they
were as shocked as I was today I wanted
to get the Beehive just to try something
different
also I'm short and this will make me a
lot taller so that's a plus
when you see the Beehive you think the
1960s
it's a nostalgic look I can't believe
that women used to wear their hair like
this on a regular basis though ceiling
probably like a half a can of hairspray
in my head I'm really nervous actually
my new beehive hairdo is just crazy it's
fun it's an attention getter it puts
smiles on people's faces today I'm
getting the mullets I don't know what I
was thinking I grew up in Augusta
Georgia where there were a lot of
mullets happening all around me it kind
of spans that spectrum of ignorant
redneck too trendy ironic hipster more
nervous than I thought I was we're
almost there
are you sure you're ready for this yeah
go for it oh I look amazing I wanna go
punch someone in the face I love my new
hairdo
it makes me a little homesick I could be
a pitcher in the major leagues this
shouldn't be surprising walking around I
shouldn't be surprised by a mohawk I
shouldn't be surprised by beehive we
need to go for it people choose a style
go for it and then change it up if you
want
you